hi everyone in this video we're going to
talk about biosynthesis of membrane
phospholipids but before I start my
video I want you to tell you that my
courses are also available in an Academy
which is India's biggest learning
platform which are more elaborate and if
you wish to join these courses you can
use my code a patent for a 10% discount
so let's turn the video so when a cell
divided from one to two cell you can
imagine the cell need to produce a hell
of a lot of membranes right in order to
make the membrane of the new cell the
endoplasmic reticulum for the new cell
so a lot of membrane biogenesis has to
be done alongside with the replication
process and all of the division drama
that that cell need to do right so
membrane bar membrane lipid biosynthesis
is a very important process for any
cells physiology or think about a
situation where the cell need to grow in
size in that situation the cell read
extra membrane right in that situation
membrane lipid biosynthesis is a very
important process so the cell membrane
is composed of mostly phospholipids out
of many type of lipids mainly they are
phospholipids now it has a hydrophobic
tail and a hydrophilic head now in a
detailed structure we would understand
the head has a group a polar group a
glycerol backbone and two hydrophobic
tails which are composed of fatty acids
are hanging out from this glycerol
backbone but how all of these components
that we just right not talked about are
actually assembled where they are
assembled and how they are delivered to
the membrane so first of all let's talk
about the structure so the hydrocarbon
tail is actually derived from fatty
acids and fatty acid synthesis is taking
place in the cytoplasm so there is a
steady state supply of fatty acids in
the cytoplasm
now the glycerol is actually derived
from glycolytic intermediates and also
in the membrane in in the cell there are
or polar charged group like serene
ethanolamine
etc present which can be added to the
growing phospholipid so we can talk
about that in this video so stay tuned
till the end so first process is the
fatty acid biosynthesis which is always
taking place in the cytoplasm so the raw
material for this is a fetal Kawai which
goes out of the mitochondria and in the
cytoplasm it forms Malinois way with the
help of the enzyme asset allocation is
not shown here but Malka way an acetyl
co a sort of condensed on fatty acid
synthase complex which is a huge complex
on top of it
acetyl co a and melon oil co a condensed
with each other and followed by several
reduction and dehydration step they form
fatty acids
now these fatty acid chains are
available in the cytoplasm for attaching
to the glycerol backbone so the next
question comes is how the glycerol is
derived or the visceral 3 phosphate is
derived so we know that in glycolysis
from glucose glyceraldehyde-3-phosphate
and dihydroxyacetone phosphate is
produced now from dihydroxyacetone
phosphate in an enzymatic process
glycerol 3-phosphate could be generated
alternatively glycerol 3-phosphate can
be generated from glycerol with the
enzymatic help
now once glycerol 3-phosphate is
generated it can be converted to a one
Silv so all 3 phosphate that means like
in one carbon position there is an acyl
group addition and this acyl group
actually came from the free fatty acid
that are present in the cytoplasm now
there is a sequential addition of
another acyl group which would
ultimately create phosphatidic acid in
the cytoplasm now all of these si group
transfer reactions are carried out by
acyl transferases which are very
important enzymes in this process and as
I'll transfer his enzymes are present in
the smooth endoplasmic reticulum in a
moment we would look at that but it's a
very important step in this reaction
ultimately
the phosphatidic acid would be the
phosphate group of the phosphatidic acid
would be chopped off by phosphatase
which is also present in the ER membrane
smooth ER membrane and diacylglycerol
would be formed which is an alcohol with
two long pati acid chain and it is
embedded in the membrane now on top of
diacylglycerol
there could be addition of the polar
group now since any biochemical
reactions need to be understand
understood from the context of a cell
biology we need to look at what happens
exactly on the smooth endoplasmic
reticulum membrane so here you can see
it's a smooth endoplasmic reticulum
membrane in pink you can see it's a
smooth endoplasmic reticulum lumen and
the white side is the cytoplasmic side
so first the raw material or the rob
backbone material is a glycerol
3-phosphate which is combined with the
fatty acid which is already present in
the cytoplasm and it is synthesized in
the cytoplasm now these two are getting
combined to each other by the as'll
transferase which are present in the
smooth endoplasmic reticulum membrane
and this is a wreck limiting step of
these reaction and it is very important
because these whole phospholipid
biogenesis path we can be modulated by
modulating these two enzymes then
phosphatidic acid is produced the
phosphoric acids phosphate group would
be chopped off using a phosphatase
enzyme and that would ultimately give
rise to diacyl glycerol which doesn't
have that phosphate group other than
that Vassar glycerol is exactly similar
to a phosphatidic acid backbone now
diastolic diacyl glycerol would be
eventually combined with polar head
groups in this example choline phospho
transfer is an enzyme which adds a polar
head group and forms phosphatidylcholine
now this is a polar head of the phosphor
the phospholipid now phosphatidylcholine
the choline part is the polar and the
membrane that the
fatty acid chains are actually
hydrophobic in nature that's why they
are deeply embedded and interacting with
each other with the hydrophobic force so
all the process of biogenesis of the
fatty acid fatty acid is taking place in
the cytoplasm and the overall process of
making membrane phospholipids is taking
place on the surface of endoplasmic
reticulum as if the raw material is
already present in the cytoplasm derived
from glycolytic pathway and derived from
fatty acid bias in the tech pathway and
they are assembled on the membrane of
smooth endoplasmic reticulum and that is
how this important bio synthetic pathway
takes place inside our cell so I hope
this video was super informative if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up and a little bit of you guys
something that I have a second channel
for those who prefer a Hindi as a
language and specially these are
dedicated to Indian people so if you
haven't yet subscribed to this channel
do check out this channel and subscribe
and for now if you like this video give
it a big thumbs up don't forget like
share and subscribe thank you